hello homies you're all mine now there
is no more baggage there is no more
extra weight there is no other name on
the laptop the spotlight is unshared you
honestly thought that Sims was the one
that watched film you thought Sims was
the one that knew the game of football
child please but to get rid of Fenric my
biggest joy an absolute clown I am less
so left out I'm right here good to see
you great to see you do I have to talk
to you now or is that my only cameo that
was it music no icon that's not how this
is gonna work but I did cover up Sims
his name the yeah it's mine hey thank
you
thanks for coming out let me just give
you guys an idea of what's going on this
week the rest of today's episode gonna
kind of give you an idea of what's going
on but we're gonna have my good friend
Justin pew starting offensive lineman
from the Arizona Cardinals he's gonna be
on sharing his thoughts on he's got a
new coach
Kliff Kingsbury having to kill snakes in
Arizona and why he's holding a grudge
against Doug Marrone I've put Josh to
work he's gonna help me out on Thursday
Sims and I did interviews with Ty law
and Edie Reed in weeks leading up to the
Hall of Fame so we talked to them and
you'll enjoy that on Thursday and then
Friday your boy Adam left go 9 o'clock
Friday night the rising stars game which
is the freshman sophomore game I am
doing play-by-play Josh and I can't
believe that they're allowing me to do
it it's gonna be me Frank Kaminsky and
Danny Green calling a Luke Adan [ __ ]
game are you gonna watch me Jess
absolutely.i what are you expecting okay
us yeah I mean you doing play-by-play
for a basketball game I have no idea
what to expect
yeah so it's it's a big week for all of
us involved and then I'm gonna be honest
guys I'm taking a week off and we've met
we haven't done this in a long time Josh
can attest to the fact that whenever we
would have vacations I would make sure
we recorded something ahead of time but
I'm pulling my Frank Lucas and I'm
taking a day a week off for any of you
that don't know I'm gonna shared some
information to you the gangster Frank
Lucas who you guys probably saw in the
movie American Gangster he had this
thing that he would do called
backtracking where he would lock himself
in a room before a big event and he
would pull the blinds and he would just
focus and that's what I'm gonna do for
the new show whether it's gonna be
called somebody in Lefko whether it's
gonna be called the left go show I don't
know but I'm gonna sort of go into and
take a vacation big things are gonna
happen on the vacation I'm very excited
but also this is where I need you guys a
33% to pull your weight to pull your 33%
I've already talked to rod Simba he's
working on a new theme song it's gonna
be great I've already hit up one of the
homies Jonah who hit me up works over at
Google he wants to help me make some
Doc's to hear better from you guys
because what I really would like is to
make this a podcast that isn't just
listening to you guys but taking things
that you guys believe can be great what
guess should we get what do you think
could be the next bear mitzvah that we
do with Tori Cohen who else do we think
we need to dive into more I'm gonna lead
this ship but the messages that you guys
have sent me in my personal DMS or the
sims and left go DMS just all the notes
about wanting to be a part of the 33%
let's go bro because the thing that I
tell all of you that want to work on the
show or intern with the show I can't
really do it but I'm telling you right
now if you have an idea rod Simba sent
me seven different show ideas of my
texts and I appreciate that as we do it
I'm shouting you guys out and if you
ever reach a point where you need a
referral or you need someone to give you
some credit
on a resume you could throw my name on
there if you do something for this show
I will stand by you whatever you need to
do because I think what we have built
and I said this on Thursday or Friday
this is the most interactive podcast
that I know that really cares about the
listeners and we care about covering the
NFL in a cool and different way from
getting different active players on
throughout the year to try and get guys
that are very knowledgeable about the
game that can go more into the film
we're gonna do all of that but I really
want to know what it is that you guys
want you're the reason we got to this
point and I want to honor that so be on
the lookout I'm gonna be tweeting out
some Doc's where you guys enter the
guests and I think it will be a lot of
fun it's been kind of crazy seeing all
the messages hasn't it
yeah it has you've been answering a lot
of DMS bro I think I might like 2,000
good for you I just say I sometimes I go
in as you're responding and I just see
them all clearing out it's really
impressive I showed it to my hairdresser
and she was like what are you doing I
like how you sign it - left go sir well
yeah they need to know yeah I'm not yeah
I think you were getting a lot of credit
and I just can't let you have the credit
anymore
I mean I answered probably 10,000 direct
messages during football season this
year so you know what and and since
you're here I want to give another
special shout out to everything that
you've done I think it was so cool to be
down there in Atlanta and have all the
homies coming up and asking you for
pictures they thought you were taller
than they thought it was very nice I was
very excited about that yeah to have
people come up to you and say you're
taller than I thought you'd be one of us
covers the best things you can hear one
of the best things you know you're damn
right I am I'm six four but I [ __ ]
love you you're the man love you too
I appreciate it all right so here's my
conversation with Justin Pugh my
absolute dog I hope you enjoy it he is
the man Europe is his transition to the
Arizona Cardinals
oh what a treat what a special occasion
I have seen this man pretty much grow up
I rooted for him to get drafted I've
rooted for him to get a big deal and all
these things keep happening just in pew
Arizona Cardinals offensive lineman
you're hairier than I remember
you're bigger than I remember how you
doing man I'm doing a Cartier bracelet
on you know you can't hide that James
Corden money it's coming in I mean I've
been feeling a lot of calls so I figure
I was like you know let me go back and
come see you before it blows up thank
you and I appreciate that watch the
video before you came so it was you
Malik Jackson the guy from Detroit
hey Sean Rock a Sean Robinson and then
another offensive lineman who I just met
for the first time I didn't okay so
we'll both blank together so neither of
us are I'm Parker yes and you were
dancing with James Corden yes and I saw
that there was a few Arizona
publications that were like Justin shows
he's got good feet yeah I don't know I
thought from your draft prospects that
we already knew that I know I mean I did
a target commercial I was yeah it's
tough to find you can't even get it on
YouTube anymore so I thought I had some
moves but that you know the Cardinals
were trying to come at me a little I'm
just realizing this now do you get
people that say man you're really like a
good talker for an offensive lineman do
you know which I which I don't get I
feel like offensive lineman if you're
out there and you want to find out more
about the NFL talk to an offensive
lineman they're the smarter guys on the
team like if you follow you know Joe
Thomas yeah of course Joe Thomas comes
up with some very very intellectual
statements where I'm like damn I don't
even think about that like he would had
that back-and-forth with Richard Sherman
is both very smart guys and it's like
you know what hats off to you two for
having a good conversation man all right
so how's Arizona just the state how is
it like living in Arizona cuz I've never
spent more than like a day there we're
separating the football yeah just as a
human as a human I love it I don't do I
don't do well with animals and there's a
lot of critters in Arizona here we have
rats the size of dogs yes
but in Arizona we have snakes we have
coyotes we have snakes again we have
scorpions we have a fighter in my
backyard it's a call the cub
grisly spy I guess what they give you
some messed up names this thing was this
big I swear to God and you're holding
like a football it looks like right
there I wouldn't got a rock and just
smash this thing to pieces see I
wouldn't have even gotten that close we
go I'm afraid of it like jumping at my
girlfriend I go out with black lights at
night and find scorpions you hit them
with a hammer that's like a hobby that's
what you guys do for fun Tech to your
land this is like old like old times out
I cook we killed a snake in my backyard
I never get in the house nothing's ever
gone in the house
holy Fred because it's just the desert
it's the desert but I live on the base
of a mountain and like there's things on
this mountain there's a little we bought
the house that people go there's a
little cat that comes around it's a lynx
cat that's like it's a little guy it's
like a 40 pound yeah literally I'm gonna
get my face ripped off when I take the
trash out so boy I always feel like
football players you get done this long
day of work you've been beating up your
body I want to come home and relax and
you're coming home and killing football
sized spiders and snakes yeah I don't
know dog-eat-dog world man in New York I
had a homeless guy living under my steps
that I had to deal with some rats once
in a while right and that was good at
stealing packages we caught him there's
no there's no getting by me but I had a
homeless guy making wine under my under
my steps in Jersey City where I where I
was living
weight like a Cabernet yeah you know
exactly was a blend actually yeah
whatever you get his hands on was in
this little bags underneath your
apartment making how does one make wine
I don't know I never you know you don't
know no no but I've seen I've seen like
movies and stuff were they like make out
Wow so how did you find out you know who
found him I didn't even find him so I
you know that guy that I was living next
door to me I helped him out with his
rant I do he was kind of like my blue
and from old-school yeah so he I used to
give him 20 bucks a week to take the
trash out so he has some extra money
yeah he wouldn't he refused to take it
he wanted to do something I was like hey
Bill you take the trash out I'll give
you 20 bucks a week so he's taking the
trash out one night he walks down there
he just sees two legs under there and we
felt bad for the guy was like ten
degrees I was one of those nights like
earlier in the week where it was so cold
that you couldn't do anything sure and
he's like just he's like I found some
guy just living under knees like so we
went down then we're talking to him he's
like making his own wine I'm like buddy
like you can stay here for the night but
like tomorrow you got
you can't I can't do that I mean you've
shown the flashlight and there's like an
entire wine cellar a bag of wine it was
like a CVS bag that he was making that I
don't know how he did I didn't ask
question it smelled awful down there I
was like hey look I know you're going
through a tough time I know it's cold
it's just I have friends I have family
matter all friends come it was just guys
I might have my house yeah yeah it was
tough so it since it's cold it was a
white it was definitely a white wine
well you've had some interesting living
situations I was living in Jersey City
it wasn't the best name no I remember
your neighborhood the apartment was
amazing but the neighborhood was an
up-and-coming yes they throw that tag on
there but I have I had a garage I had I
had a place to park my car and that's
that you can't put a price on how
different as a human is living in
Arizona in New York cuz now I've been in
New York for about five years and I'm
completely biased wherever I go I'm like
this is inconvenient I can walk out of
my apartment to get anything so what
does that been like I Love New York New
York is where I grew up
yeah came a man in New York I feel like
her a little bit more than adolescent
boy but I love it here I go I always
come back here Arizona is a lot
different a lot more outdoorsy
activities people are going hiking
people are mountain biking everywhere
they're walking they're in shape yeah
New York were you saying about New York
yes trust me I'm a big guy there's no
pizza out there I can't I'm struggling
if I even though I've had really good
success too and I can't I just can't
find my prince treat man
Oh Prince treats your one are you
getting like the pepperonis that curl up
and stuff the best wow I've never had
that slice I've done like all the the
was at Beecher Street beat Bleecker yeah
I mean it's
I've waited my lines for 30 minutes I've
done that whole thing I got you
connected next time you're going there
okay I send that I'll send the heads-up
but don't let don't let me get too big
because I'm definitely changing numbers
here the cord and back to the coordinate
yes uh when you sign a new contract like
I hosted the match right with Samuel
Jackson Charles Barkley which was
amazing by the way what I see it yet I'm
surprised you're answering my calls now
you're right well I'm just saying my
phone blew up for that and I can't give
anybody anything when you sign a new
contract
you have like what was the longest time
that you went from talking to someone
that they contacted you like did you get
like an elementary school teacher
already yeah really yeah well the one
thing that helped me I did change my
number going into when I was gonna sign
it yes so I still if I needed to reach
out to someone I have all my contacts
but getting to me as though I got off
Facebook because Facebook you have all
the high school all the friends on the
other crap
it's from college it's still like want
to hang out and it's like him for like
57 times I'm like no Zach it's not
happening and they know like they'll see
your story that I know you're here yeah
right around the corner in case that's
it it's tough because you you don't want
to feel like you're ever dissing anybody
but like I moved on yeah you moved on
let's just stay on our own lanes when I
lived in Nebraska I did a story with
this old farmer and it was right when
Facebook was being opened up to the
masses and I said maybe you should get
on Facebook you can connect with like
all your high school friends and he goes
I'm old I don't want to talk to anybody
and I was like I want to be you when I
grow up
yeah you just find your Island and you
stay on your Island and you never come
back so speaking of jail no no I'm just
trying to figure out something you go
into a new locker room do you fight the
biggest guy in the locker room how do
you how did you adjust we have this dude
speaking of prison who's a little prison
esque but you know Rob Kim deechi horse
is he the most athletically gifted guy
I've ever been around like he's 310
pounds but he's got a six-pack I mean
he's yes explosion off the line he's had
studies martial arts he's in Sweeney
Todd and play during the season he's an
interesting cat he's got one leg that he
has tattooed perfectly it's like
beautiful and the other one like his
friends like practice on so he has like
a like a doodle paper leg and he's got
her actual yeah like I followed him on
Instagram when he went to Japan and I
was like this guy is not your typical
football player but wait he's enormous
he's enormous but he's just he's a
specimen the guy like there's a reason
why this guy is big yeah who he was so I
had to go in a fight Rob the first day
me and Rob had been fighting everything
I got there but he's also the nicest guy
so like we'll get in a fistfight on the
field wait you will I thought you were
kidding no no we fought we fought the
indoor no TAS
wow that's the second fight you
no TAS you had one with New York too
it's a great one look it up on YouTube
just an uppercut in putting this vicious
uppercut on de montreuil more I remember
I came on the podcast I was like fight
of the weekend forgetful Mayweather
Pacquiao Pew just leveled this guy I
fought Damon Harrison if all snacks a
few times that's that's a scary man
that's a big man what like what is your
shirt like how does it happen with
defensive lineman is it just weeks into
Oh TA where it's hot and you're annoyed
and like they hold on a little bit extra
like what causes the oth it's usually me
I'm the instigator confident I'm not the
biggest guy amusement offensive lineman
I'm not the biggest guy in the room but
I'd like to find out where I stack up on
the totem pole like I'm gonna get my ass
kicked sometimes yeah and that just
happens and I'm cool with that I'm cool
with not being one on the totem pole
yeah I want to see if I'm two three four
five see where I'm at yeah and you find
out it's a that's a you find out and I'm
I'm more of a type that if we're
fighting at the end of the day we're
gonna laugh it off and go back to being
boys I'm not that hold a grudge type but
what if they don't
what if they hold the grudge like have
you dealt with that yeah they can't hold
a grudge against me I'm gonna calm to
mess with them I'll go sitting down next
to him at dinner we're gonna I'm gonna
be here until you like French Street
pizza yeah the Olive Branch is always is
always a good I've had gotten in fights
where guys don't wanna do coaches like
that like do coaches like that the
energy at practice was up or are they
kind of like depending like it depends
on the coach but it also depends on the
situation like all right P like three
times in the past week like chill chill
out but the coffins like if there's
another fight you're both getting
suspended contract conduct detrimental
to the team timeout you were under
Coughlin Coughlin how long were you with
Coughlin two years
what is coffin like cuz we joke around
that he's like my alarm goes off at 4:30
I am awake and now I go to practice what
does he like that leaf that's how he is
I mean he is like by the book every time
you go by him he'll always have
something to say like it's always be
like what do you spit you're spending
too much time in the training room what
are you doing in there yeah but I was
always scared of coughing cuz I was only
in my second year I was like don't walk
by don't make eye contact but he would
always sit and talk to you yeah he would
notice if you were wearing black or
white socks if they weren't the right
issued socks you're getting a fine Wow
didn't have the right shorts on the
wrong color tights like he was so
aware of what was going on of everything
I feel one second late you're getting
fined in Arizona is not not the same way
and mcadoo I'm sure was the same way too
he carried some of us think we still
operated on coffin time but it was a
little bit but a little bit different
but McAdoo is my guy back in ER he gets
a bad rap okay
Here I am someone that a long time
during that time was going this guy
ain't right it's just not working
I think the slicked back hair it's kind
of I saw him recently you know he
interview for ROC position I saw that
with cliff he's back sleeve was rolled
up the suit was a little baggy like he's
back he's officially back hairs all
messed up hair was too it was it was
slicked but it wasn't like did the team
talk to him about a slicked back hair or
was it this is the coach we shouldn't
say a player's joked with them for about
and how did he take it he was fine he
rolled the punches I mean what's he
gonna tell his messing with you you got
to take that on the chin a thousand
percent but I will say that yes sell me
on McAdoo he's back by the way he was
sleeve rolled up baggy shirt looked
uncomfortable in his suit that's what
you were doing it and I'm like he's back
he's back now he gets a bad rap because
he messed with Eli like that when you
mess with Eli you mess with NFL royalty
things don't go well for ya you saw what
happened when that whole situation
occurred yeah the GM and the head coach
didn't even make it back to New York man
I remember fresh Francesa just going off
on him with that and now I look at
Francesa and he doesn't even know what
Photoshop is which is a fun thing all
right Arizona my first question is how
is the rosin one what is he like as a
person when he was coming out of college
and I heard the nickname as I mean
there's a Jewish man I was like this is
my Sandy Koufax this is what I've always
wanted he had some great moments this
year he had some learning moments this
year what was your first interaction
where you went oh he could be a big-time
player of this league did you have that
moment at all was OTAs because Sam
Bradford was the starting quarterback
was everyone was told Shann will be the
starting quarterback but an OTA Sam's
knee still weren't he wasn't he wasn't
ready to go to her no TAS so Rosen as
soon as we got the OTAs day one he was
starting quarterback
and he came in he came into the huddle
and he like had a presence about him a
confidence about him and there's no
teach there there's no coaching he'll
either guy either has it or he doesn't
have you have it and you automatically
gain respect by the way you handle
yourself in the huddle I mean Sam's with
price told you sure you know if you
don't go in there with confidence and
then speak loudly and clearly guys not
gonna trust him they don't trust you
they won't play for you he came in he
accomplished that right off the bat
which I was very impressed with I never
been around a rookie quarterback right
where I've been around any lie Manning
who knew the offense better than priced
most of the coaches knew the offense so
he came in and handled that but he got
dealt a tough hand in this first year
the starting five offensive linemen go
down aq Shipley who was our starting
center at a time who was a vet ten year
guy I've been around a while he goes
down who's gonna help him make it was
the bunt or yeah so then Mason Cole
comes in who's our backup rookie Center
and no nocte Mason but he's learned he's
learning as Josh is learning so you lose
your starting five offensive linemen
throughout the year we all five all five
and the two backups so you're starting
seven offensive linemen which normally
that's all a team carries yeah they're
all gone so you're out there I'm not and
the other guys came in and they played
well or they did some things and Josh
had it learned some things but it was
tough for him for sure but Josh still
has a ways to go there's times where you
know Josh wants to revert back to ways
he's done it in the past just like
anyone was he was comfortable how they
did it at UCLA yeah the NFL operates a
little differently in college football
how different is it if you were like if
your buddies were asking how would you
explain it to him oh I was in a
different situation no you're Doug
bonuses my head coach so I was running
the Saints offense when I was at
Syracuse
so really helped me out going into the
NFL and these things weren't completely
foreign to me yeah but a lot of times
these college teams they're just holding
up signs like I run the you know Kenny
Powers play whatever whatever that is
whatever however they talk about that
and we were at Syracuse we dumbed it
down till we have like seven plays on a
wristband so Ryan NASA would come up and
just be like all right we have one left
here and everyone's got out there and
did right I think there's a place for
that in the NFL I think the speed helps
limit what the defense's can do and you
see a lot of teams going up tempo so I
think that really has emerged as
something that is feasible the NFL look
at McVeigh they have you watch what they
do they were on
basically the same formation in the same
place they're just so efficient with it
that it's incredible and then you look
at the Patriots and you watch that game
and how when it was almost like it was
almost like watching like an artist
paint I mean it was I was gonna use a
different analogy but I decide I said no
cursing then oh yeah we have a problem I
like to curse a lot I think it's over I
said get your point across have you
cursed yet in this interview I don't
think I have I know when the turn I know
when I flip the switch
would you like to yeah what's your
favorite curse [ __ ] me - I say never my
grandmother my mom gets mad at me I
realize I'm saying you know my problem
is is when I get animated I start
talking like this and my mom will go
you're cursing and you don't talk like
that
I'm like oh great here we go but what's
the hand talkin is that like an Italian
thing is that a Jewish thing I think
it's a I watched people on television
growing up and I wanted to do that and I
feel like Steven likes Stewart my god
yeah I just think I'm a lunatic so it
comes out what was it oh this is my
other question have with like normal
people
can you watch football with people no I
hate my friends I hate watching I hate
them all I hate why I get invited to
watch just so many people I can't do it
I sit there and I obviously I have to
watch the Eagles games when I go home
with my friends and I'm just like
they're like oh he's the best player
ever I'm like that was actually a blown
cover he's like he tripped and fell or
like what am i how can you see was so
wide open I'm like he actually wasn't
even trying to go to that receiver and
what you don't even realize is they're
doing it more because you're there
because they want to impress you they
want to go oh what a great throw but
like if you weren't there they weren't
gonna do that and they're like trying to
drop coverages on me and I'm like look
guys I'm an offensive lineman I do know
your basic open close coverage I don't
know it as well as an NFL quarterback
yeah I don't know [ __ ] about NFL
quarterback play I don't know what oh
yeah I don't know where like they're the
release point how they're like what all
those intricacies so I stay in my lane
yeah I'm obviously want to learn more
about it but they're like I played
Madden once I know what cover two is I
know what cover three is I know I know
with the difference between a dog and a
blitz oh I'm gonna try to use that and
they and they don't know anything you
talked about seven offensive linemen
going down you get a coach and then you
lose the coach in the same year just the
experience for you
I mean this hat you had to learn so much
about the other side of the NFL this
year the past two years from from New
York took us explain it this way when I
was in New York I was dating my high
school sweetheart I was I was in love I
didn't care who knew it traffic traffic
destined to change my life and then she
just left me out in the cold didn't even
give me a call goodbye just just left me
Wow yeah I'm still salty at the Giants
for the way I didn't realize yeah well
they knew they couldn't afford you in
Weston yeah they knew they knew that and
they had other guys had to pay O'Dell
you have Landon Collins coming up so I'm
I get the business side now but at the
same point but at the time I never
thought I would leave New York I did
everything they ever asked me they were
just left me at left guard I think I'm
one of the best cars in the NFL but I
was abandoned I was left tackle one week
I was left card I was right guard
it wasn't growth I was Center if I
needed to be in some games in
emergencies so I'm salty for that and
I'll take that hit as like being soft or
being emotional about it but it's an
emotional game so I get to I see the
business side of the free agency because
I thought I was gonna get paid I thought
I was getting Andrew Norwell money
because that's how I value myself Chuck
and he and really and he's a great
player don't get me wrong but like it's
cuz he was good going into free agency I
was good and got hurt going into France
which was my downfall so it's very very
humbling to say I guess it's kind of
it's how I said I got an [ __ ] saying
this but he was getting 13 I'm getting
nine I'm like damn I thought I was you
know the guy yeah but you know what
reduced deduce this down to something
that anyone can understand if you
believe you're better at your job or
equal to somebody and you see they're
getting paid more no matter if there's
six zeroes at the end or five or four
it's gonna make you feel kind of way if
I see someone get a job and I go man I
could do that better than them and there
get oh yeah it would make me a nitwit
and not only was it that it was who paid
him the jags paid him Tom Coughlin Tom
Coughlin paid him rotate him all my guys
that were the Giants are with Syracuse
that were my guys yeah they also didn't
want me so I was like wait so the Giants
Tina drafted me didn't want me the guys
that know me the best the guys that are
in our in Jax know they didn't want me
I'm like damn I'm like Mike is anyone
gonna want me yeah and then the
Cardinals came in and Steve came our
general manager he we had some
you know mutual connections or it is
nice to be wanted it is nice to go to a
place that wants you there and that
makes me want to play even harder for
those guys because they're like you know
what we see in you what's other people
don't mmm and then the coaching thing
because I didn't know we were gonna get
a one-and-done situation I didn't
believe that was gonna happen either I
thought he would get a second chance
with this year just cuz we had so many
injuries and yeah it's things of that
nature but those things were above my
paygrade there's things that were
happening with the defense inside of the
ball where we have a 314 we brought in a
4-3 coach how are we gonna handle that
so I guess there were some fundamental
disagreements on how the team was gonna
go moving forward
have you met cliff yet I have Oh smooth
okay first question is he as attractive
as a person as he is on camera
yeah for sure he's got the sharp-dressed
suit he's coming I met him he just
landed on the private helicopter with
the owner I mean with the Ryan Gosling
glasses exactly and I think yeah but but
Wilkes was also very smooth okay
he was Denzel Washington I know
sometimes they will put like he was the
man so we've I've had some pretty smooth
coaches and then McAdoo who's he's back
he's back just smash attacks but exactly
so what's your vibe a cliff and are you
excited I'm excited I'm excited
obviously like everyone's trying to like
chime in and everyone has an opinion on
of course I don't know what kind of
football mind he has yet I haven't sat
down I haven't heard the offense that
we're gonna be installing I know from he
talking to people that he that a lot of
the NFL guys will go to him and get and
get some ideas like he's on the
forefront of your boy Davis Webb played
for him and said amazing things every
guy that's played for Matt said he's the
man you want him on your side right we
surrounded him also with some veterans
mhm so for you know he's a young guy
he's never had head coaching experience
in the NFL obviously at Texas Tech we
got fans Joseph who was just a head
coach to the NFL hey look this is what
went wrong for me in Denver don't want
that happen to you
we got Sean Kugler who's offensive line
coach who was in Pittsburgh with the
great offensive line he was a man he was
in Denver he was a head coach at UTEP
for a little bit
he's our offensive line coach what's he
like I haven't won I haven't met okay
because offensive line coaches are like
the best the guy that is no longer with
the
was my old line coach last year Ray
Brown one of the best human beings you
ever meet played for 20 years in the NFL
he didn't get his big deal on of years
20 years 20 to 0 as offensive correct he
didn't get his big deal till year 10
imagine that he was the fried thing he
was a first guard to make a million
dollars Wow play for San Francisco
played for the Redskins for a while when
you saw
did you watch Hard Knocks and you saw
Bob Wiley with the hood
was there any party that's like I'd like
to play for that guy no I mean yeah I
get it
the your your gorilla he's funny I'll
laugh with that but I'm like I want to
win football games I'll tell you the the
offensive line coach in Seattle right
now Mike Solari yes is is a guru he's
unbelievable and I we bashed heads in
New York because I like to have fun I
like to joke around and he's like all
business he's an actual robot he's the
nicest guy ever but an actual robot and
he's the one who told me he's like look
you're not gonna want to hear this but
you might have to take like a one-year
deal with the team because you're not
gonna get the money you're looking for
mm-hmm in during the season he's getting
hurt he's like he's not gonna pay you
that's what I'm wondering with - Marcus
Lawrence right now he's getting surgery
and I'm like I don't know but what's
again done I mean I think I saw a
shoulder surgery I don't know yeah but I
mean if it's alive in an offensive
lineman and I was a back with an
offensive lineman you have a back end
you know I mean it's it's tough all
right I don't wanna take up too much
your time because I know that your
schedule is crazy but I guess I don't
know so I would say that the Arizona
Cardinals when I look at them from afar
someone that covers the entire NFL and
looked at the whole league they were
from the very beginning written off like
I think even before the year whether it
was like the Tyrann Mathieu situation
players leaving it was a new coach with
a rookie quarterback no one really
expected anything so expectations were
low
Larry is back I think the offensive line
being healthy in my gambling mind which
you're not allowed to say I go oh it's
seven guys getting back people can sleep
on them
why is everybody sleeping on the Arizona
Cardinals next year what could happen
that could prove everybody I mean when
you're the worst team in football record
wise no one's going to give you a chance
but if you look at why things went the
way they
and cat space was a little limited we
made some investments in the quarterback
position it didn't pan out that's a lot
of money I mean we have a lot of cat
space I mean it's we have a number-one
draft pick and every round obviously
yeah people are going to be coming for
that number one pick I don't know what
we do with it and then we're the number
one in the waiver wire so we can get
some guys and you can see teams make
that bounce back quick look at the LA
Rams for example I mean they were the
laughingstock of the NFL if two years
ago during the Superbowl now so I've
seen crazier things happen the most
talented talented team I've ever been on
was the Giants team two years ago and we
were the second worst human football
jeez
all right my last question is what does
it like to face Aaron Donald I hate him
because he's so cause he's so damn good
I saw him in person I've never seen a
human that thick like my back but like
if no one told you he was a d-line and
wouldn't you think he's like a like a
fighter or a wrestler or like he's a
bowling ball and every inch of him is
muscle all right so you he lines up over
you yeah what is that experience like do
well against him so he goes to the other
side just like get him there's there's
no key there's a category of deal I'm
and who's the best there's every other
guy and then there's Aaron Donald like
there's no it's that wide even Fletcher
communist what's your Cox reel and
Fletcher Cox is very very good he's a
pro bow all pro Jones a caring Donald is
like a changed the game type of player
he's a Lawrence Taylor of our time where
like when have you ever seen I mean
Warren Sapp man he would change the game
on the inside technique yeah if you have
a guy that can penetrate up the middle
you can put guys on the edge to chip
guys it's very hard to get two bodies on
Aaron Donald which a lot of teams slide
to him right but you say you're putting
the backside guard and let me scheme
that so I'm sure you watch all this film
and you look at a guy you go okay I can
take this away I'm gonna give up a
little here but I'm gonna take this away
what is your mindset when you face him
is it is it just don't get blown back or
well it depends you have to know when
you're getting help and kind of funnel
him to your hell yeah but if you do that
too quick he's gonna blow through the
other guys you can't guys you'll see so
many times they're sliding to him and he
splits it because the one guys like I
let me make him go inside but he gets
beat so so quickly inside of the other
guys in trouble and he splits him and he
gets to the quarterback or on the
backside of a run play where he just
blows by the guard
she tries to put a hand on him because
he talked during games no he doesn't
really talk and Nina doesn't in Dhamma
consumed he doesn't really talk so
there's just the silent and you don't
and you don't poke the bear leave your
own until I mean I we're playing them
and someone started getting into it with
him I'm like shut up
don't don't say anything to him don't I
don't get Khalil Matt going I don't get
von miller going yeah you don't get him
going and we're and we're good so
Donald's clearly above Mac too in your
mind yeah
I think is I think you put it tight in
like a Rob like you'll chip him a little
bit of chip him a little bit I played
against von Miller a few years ago and
he's and he's unbelievable but they're
not as powerful as Aaron Donald so they
scare you Matt can run you've seen him
run guys yes
so obviously Mac is in the in that
conversation but I just think Aaron
Donald's and it pains me to say this
because yeah you want to spare this to
her go against I know where I'm at and
the total I'm gonna keep getting after
him yeah I guess that would be my only
other question is when was the first
time that he got a hand on you and you
felt the power and went wow that didn't
even show up on film at Pittsburgh when
I was at Syracuse I played against
college yeah because when I was at
college no one gave me problems I want
to get Chandler Jones every day and
Chandler was very very good but Chandler
took a step when he got to the NFL like
he chant he realized he had an eighty
whatever and reach and started using it
yeah I played against Bruce Irving I
played against my pair you all
first-round pick guys but I didn't
struggle with them like I snuck over
there and Donna like he got sub under
you cuz he's like six feet tall and
there's nothing you can do because he's
more powerful than a guy that's 350
pounds unreal well good luck to you
health wrists is good and it was good
and the knee is good everything's good
alright as long as you don't let those
snakes and spiders get to you I see a
good season ahead I really did a good
year appreciate you coming in thank you
that was my guy Justin pew not gonna lie
did pretty good in the left co-host
chair now this was before I didn't even
tell him what was happening that there
would be an opening but I'm just saying
if
the left go podcast whatever this
becomes kind of becomes an American Idol
of searching for that perfect co-host I
think that pew might be up there and I
want to know what you guys think about
him you know do I need to bring back pew
I really want to know all I definitely
know and Nick take the two-shot here is
Josh Fredrick wasn't gonna make it I
mean you're co-hosting earlier I
I cannot extend you a rose but you know
what let me translate to something you
would understand Josh the tribe has
spoken
the tribe has spoken I do understand
that you do that's a language I speak um
do you want to get any survivor stuff
out of your system before you're done I
think my Hawaiian sling monologue last
week was all I needed people really
loved that well did ya okay well I love
you do you want to say anything to the
homies yeah yeah yeah yeah you got to
give a last last shout-out to the homey
I thought I was done on Friday uh I love
you all this is this experience has been
absolutely awesome
much I feel like I'm gonna give the same
speech that Simms gave cuz I'm pretty
much agree with everything he said sad
to see it end yeah pump for the future
all right 33% so Josh cannot be the left
co-host we learned that today yeah and
it's a missed opportunity
but coming up on Thursday we are gonna
have two more interviews it is going to
be ty law and it's gonna be Ed Reid and
I'm gonna be honest it's the last time
that you're gonna hear Sims and me do in
the pod but it's cool because we always
connect with these guys we hyped up ty
and Reed takes you you realize why this
dude is so smart and why he's so cocky
and it really really is special but I
appreciate you guys as always you are
the man
I am the lef koe I know you said it at
home and that's really all that matters
you guys are the [ __ ] we'll be back
later P well